Despite being among the most remarkable and
ambitious shows in TV history, HBO unceremoniously
canceled Deadwood after just three seasons.
In 2019 13 years later the show finally returned
with a wrap-up film.
So just why did HBO get rid of Deadwood in
the first place?
The business of making television is somewhat
separate from the business of broadcasting
it.
While many networks are part of entertainment
conglomerates that also include production
companies, the studios that make TV shows
can shop a series around to different networks,
which then pay a hefty licensing fee for the
right to air it.
Studios may also team up to make shows, particularly
expensive ones like Deadwood.
HBO is a division of Warner Media, and the
network co-produced the show with Paramount,
which held the international rights.
That necessitated a lot of talks and contracts
between Warner and Paramount over splitting
the profits from Deadwood.
Those companies reached an impasse about their
arrangement before a fourth season of Deadwood
could go into production, and so both parties
walked away from the table, in effect canceling
the show.
"And here's my counteroffer to your counteroffer:
Go f--- yourself."
That may not be as exciting as a standoff
in the thoroughfare, but it's the reality.
Then-HBO chief executive and chairman Chris
Albrecht told the Chicago Tribune,
"Not having a fourth season of Deadwood is
not the result anyone wanted."
By that time, the possibility had disappeared
like a dead miner's body into Mr. Wu's pigpen.
But the network really did fight to keep Deadwood
alive.
HBO wanted creator David Milch to concentrate
his efforts on his next show for the network,
the surreal, spiritual and short-lived surfing
drama John from Cincinnati, so executives
offered him a six-episode final season of
Deadwood, as opposed to the traditional 12.
He turned it down.
Milch said:
"It seemed to me that some sort of partial
order for the show would make it impossible
to do anything but superimpose all sort(s)
of interpretations that would deprive it of
its own emotion."
Then, just days before Deadwood's third and
final season premiered in 2006, HBO announced
that those episodes would not be the end of
the line, as the network had accepted Milch's
pitch to wrap up the series with a pair of
two-hour specials.
Network spokesperson Nancy Lesser said,
"He found a way to bring closure to the narrative
and remain true to the themes of the material
and spirit of the characters."
Those two specials ended up as just one movie,
released 13 years later.
Deadwood wasn't just canceled because the
people who write the checks had a fight about
money.
It also earned a de facto cancellation because
of some passive-aggressive behavior by HBO.
According to TV Series Finale, Deadwood wasn't
"officially" canceled at all.
The cast's so-called options simply weren't
picked up.
An option is a clause in an actor's contract
that gives a show's production company the
chance to sign the performer on for more episodes
at the end of the contract's term.
In the case of Deadwood, actors' contracts
were valid for three seasons, with an option
for a fourth.
This binds an actor to a show, preventing
them from leaving to make other TV shows or
movies, thus saving writers from the task
of explaining character absences.
But the fourth-season option for Deadwood's
stars wasn't exercised.
The actors were essentially released from
their obligation to Deadwood, meaning they
were available to go do other things.
HBO and the show's producers essentially said,
"you're no longer needed," which is just another
of saying, "show's over, go home."
"No deceit too prolonged.
No errand too demeaning.
Get outta here!
No rebuke too vile!"
Television is a numbers game.
By and large, the shows that bring in the
most overall viewers are the ones that get
a rubber-stamp renewal season after season.
HBO is an ad-free network and operates on
a paid subscription model, but it still has
to take ratings into effect.
If it airs shows that not enough people are
watching, then it's a waste of the company's
money.
It's also not going to bring in many more
people willing to pay an extra $10 or $20
a month on their cable bill.
This was the problem with Deadwood.
Despite the critical praise and awards attention
from the Emmys and Golden Globes, it never
exactly pulled in Game of Thrones-level numbers.
The first season of Deadwood averaged a respectable
4.5 million viewers, but only about 2.4 million
viewers cared enough about Al Swearengen and
Seth Bullock to tune in for season two.
A downward ratings trajectory made an early
cancellation inevitable.
Every episode of Deadwood was densely packed
with inscrutable characters and complicated
dialogue.
"To inform within decency's limits.
We've had this discussion before."
"Citizens better die pustulatin' than touch
indecent ink."
Deadwood was already a difficult show to make,
even before creator David Milch's tendency
toward last-minute rewrites.
According to IndieWire, actor Timothy Olyphant
told the audience at Film Independent Presents'
"An Evening with Deadwood" about the time
Milch came to him in his trailer to tell him
that he'd just decided to kill off Bullock's
stepson, which required a complete reworking
of the show.
Olyphant joked:
"The season became about that kid dying.
[The decision] happened at lunch."
According to Vulture, Milch was a consummate
perfectionist who hung out on the Deadwood
set, barking out dialogue suggestions from
off-camera and ordering scenes reshot, even
if he wasn't the credited writer or director.
Ian McShane, who played Swearengen, remembers
rewrites coming in so late that the pages
were still warm from the copy machine.
More takes means more money, and Deadwood
wasn't a cheap show to begin with.
Period-appropriate sets and costumes, horses,
wagons, animal handlers, and a large regular
cast all contributed to a budget of around
$4.5 million per episode at its most expensive.
It must have been hard for HBO to justify
keeping Deadwood around when it didn't bring
in huge ratings.
Long before the era of Peak TV brought high-quality
content to most every cable network and streaming
service, HBO held itself up as the home of
prestige television, bearing the famous slogan,
"It's not TV, it's HBO."
The premium channel carefully selects what
handful of shows it will air at any given
time, and while it tries to offer a little
something for everyone, it can often find
itself with a certain "brand."
In the mid-2000s, the flavor of HBO was solidly
hip, envelope-pushing shows set in the present
day.
A sampling of its lineup at the time included
Curb Your Enthusiasm, The Comeback, Extras,
The Sopranos, and Big Love.
Among those shows about cranky TV writers,
deluded actresses, cranky British actors,
depressed mob bosses, and plural marriage
sat Deadwood, an often brutal, slow-moving
Western where the characters talked like they
were doing Shakespeare with more profanity.
It was an anomaly on HBO's schedule, and it
was simply too weird to live.
"Always superfluous, bloodshed!
The deeper damage is best."
While Deadwood was never a ratings smash,
casting directors and filmmakers were among
those aware of the show's undeniably talented
ensemble cast.
By the show's third season in 2006, many Deadwood
performers were already looking to move on
to other roles and other challenges.
Ian McShane had roles in a number of films
lined up, including voice work in The Golden
Compass and Kung Fu Panda, and live action
parts in Hot Rod and The Seeker: The Dark
is Rising.
Molly Parker showed up in Hollywoodland and
The Wicker Man, along with another period
series, the '70s-set CBS drama Swingtown.
Timothy Olyphant jumped right into Live Free
or Die Hard and Hitman.
For many parties, Deadwood's cancellation
came at the right time in their careers.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.